if you notice that facial recognition is
everywhere at the moment it's how we
unlock our phones tag people on Facebook
and as some US airports it's being used
to speed up the process of boarding an
aircraft but there are also concerns
about this technology as well from
lawmakers and civil rights groups
I'm here with Gretchen Greene a computer
vision expert and lawyer who's going to
help us understand this technology thank
you for joining us Gretchen and Don
great to be here the uses that are
really driving the public debate right
now or around the government users and
so we've seen that the city of San
Francisco where we are now recently
banned
use of facial recognition by its
agencies Oakland across the bay did so -
and so did Somerville Massachusetts it's
very unusual for a government at any
level to completely ban a technology
what's driving driving this right so one
of the uses or maybe the primary use
that I think drives that is law
enforcement use and so besides it
borders it's also local government
you've seen it on TV episodes where on
crime shows they can just sort of search
it's like oh that's who that is
one of the issues is how that intersects
with overall surveillance possibilities
the thing which is unprecedented right
now is the number of surveillance
cameras both private and public if you
were to connect those into a network
where it's easy to get that data in a
continuous way and then you combine it
with tools like facial recognition that
could allow the automated processing of
the data you could track everyone
potentially all of the time backwards -
as far as you had surveillance data and
we're not there but if you've got a
camera there still the question of can
the police get a search warrant or can
they just ask you for it tell us a
little bit about this technology so how
does how does it work and how these
systems being being made ultimately what
it does is it's finding patterns and
there's multiple layers that are finding
different kinds of patterns but you can
imagine with your eyes that if you
really simplified it so you zoom the way
out and you had this blurry image
there's kind of a dark band right here
so that's in one of the layers one of
the patterns that the model is picking
up and then you have to give it
examples of
pictures that you've labeled either it
can be a yes no there's a face in the
picture there's not
or it can be where the face is or it can
be who the face is and it might be
millions of examples that you need to
give it for it to figure out what are
the patterns that it should be looking
for where does that data come from well
it depends actually on who is using it
where is government get images so I
would say government databases
departments of motor-vehicle State
Department records those kinds of
records are starting to be assembled
into databases that the FBI for instance
has access to not all states but some
where does big tech and images from as a
primary source
well people post them all the time I
said what you would need is a picture of
someone and a label that said who is
this so if you put up a picture or you
see a picture and you say oh well this
is my friend Jack and this is my friend
Sue now you've provided them that label
training data that they can use for
their facial recognition algorithms it's
also gotten much more accessible so not
only the big tech companies with deep
pockets and a lot of scientists can do
this sort of thing so it's been
proliferating absolutely showing up in a
lot of different places commercial all
kinds of uses how are they being used
private security so it's being used at
large events there was a report in China
about someone who had an outstanding
warrant or the equivalent going to a big
concert and being identified by facial
recognition it's being used for
advertisements a closely related
technology is a motion recognition which
can be done in a lot of ways but one of
them is through looking at the face so
if you can see how someone reacts to an
electronic billboard outside a store you
can change the electronic billboard to
try to make it more enticing to them
it's also being used in education with
robot human interactions having a robot
it has like a nice personality but
trying to interact and so it has to
understand when someone is looking at it
yeah so a really broad span and lots of
them seem fairly innocuous some of them
I guess make something a bit unusual we
don't expect billboards to
to scan our faces or look at us and why
does the government want this technology
so in law enforcement for example what
what benefits do they see from having
the ability to search faces anything to
me law enforcement is interested in
tools to help them do their job better
if you've got a database full of
pictures and their identities and then
you have a picture of somebody from the
7-eleven that got robbed right now you
can take that picture and maybe pass it
around to the officers who do work in
that area you'd maybe go around the
neighborhood say does anybody know who
this is
well one that'll take longer but the
other thing is maybe nobody knows and
maybe that picture is somewhere in this
database but your database has 10,000
pictures in it it'll take a very long
time to go one by one it'll matter
probably less in the case of a 7/11 that
you find them quickly but the longer
that it takes to solve the case the less
likely that it is to be solved and there
are other kinds of crimes kidnappings
where it's very important to solve
quickly raises a question that a lot of
civil liberties groups arts which is
about what if the federal recognition
software is wrong what if it
misidentified someone and I've heard
concerns that you know there will be
different error rates for different
demographics and different communities
right so there's two kinds of concerns
to have what if it's right should we be
using something in a certain way at all
and then what if it's wrong even if it's
only wrong sometimes what are the
effects of it being wrong it changes how
the police officer will react which
could be good or bad we want the officer
to be safe but they will be more likely
to take more extreme action and to think
that they're in danger when maybe
they're actually not so for instance if
it's a misidentification there is
research out of MIT where dark skin is
not as likely to be correctly identified
as light particularly women with dark
skin not as likely to be correctly
identified there are also general
concerns about the effects on anyone
from any community of just knowing that
the government
maybe tracking your face maybe watching
you even if I trust the government I do
care I would rather live in a world
where I feel like I have some privacy
even in public spaces that not not all
is known because if people know where
you are you might not go there you might
not do those things even though there
are things that are bedrock of what we
think people in this country should be
able to do for instance coming out as
gay is less problematic professionally
now than it was in the US but still
potentially problematic and so if an
individual wants to make the choice when
to publicly disclose that then they
don't want facial recognition technology
identifying that they are walking down
the street to the LGBTQ Center so there
are kinds of membership issues of
certain groups in society where we're
not as a government trying to stop or as
a society really trying to stop certain
kinds of actions we're not trying to
stop people from going to church not
trying to stop them from going to
community centers but we will if they
are afraid of what will the implications
be in an environment that is hostile to
for instance a certain ethnicity or a
certain religion so really is very
difficult to Oldtown from either
government facial recognition or all
commercially it sounds it is very
difficult and that's one reason that it
is more controversial than some other
things like fingerprints would be
because it can be done at a distance
when you don't know it's being done and
in a way that you it's very difficult to
opt out and some people might might
think that well there would be some kind
of privacy laws or something that might
restrict ideas like that I mean is there
any regulation at the federal or state
level that specifically regulates facial
recognition see more happening on the
the local levels state or city right now
then at the federal the federal
government has not said we are
regulating this and therefore local
governments cannot and then because of
that we're seeing a patchwork of states
and cities thinking about doing
something I wonder what do you think the
future looks like it are we in a period
that we will look back on and say wow
this technology was really unfettered
back then but now we have some
protections is that where things are
going or always is it too late and this
is just how it's going to be there
aren't that many companies where facial
recognition is their core business and
it's not deeply embedded in what the
government is doing and how are
functioning it were I don't think it
would be necessarily too late to say as
a society what are the implications and
the effect that government use of
technologies that can be used for
surveillance like facial recognition can
have on other rights so freedom of
speech expression religion do we want
this or not this is a choice that we're
making and there are a number of ways to
say that we don't want to make that
choice or that we do we should decide as
a society thank you for joining us
Gretchen I'll be interesting to see how
all this plays out good to be here